all right he wants to show me a video
about some dude who's are going to a
black barber for the first time which is
crazy and you can tell my eyes ain't
never been to a black barber either so
I'm about to live vicariously through
this [ __ ] you've never been to a barber
period to shame yes
oh I go to get my hair cut today and I
live in Norco and it's all white people
right so I'll go to the white barber
like I've been doing her for the past 18
years I go in there there's my barber
and there's a little line and there's
this black dude I've never seen it
before he's a new hire and this angel
from sent sent directly from heaven is
just there and no one's going to them
cuz we did some racist [ __ ] I
don't ask me and I was like you know
what the bros knew i'ma give him a
chance I'll sit down in his seat and
everyone's kind of looking at me like
and the dude is whining J so I already
know he knows like is she you got it J's
on you got some true religion jeans on
and flying but yo and then he just wears
a typical [ __ ] but here's what you lost
money your stereotypical [ __ ] you said
there's a [ __ ] got J's and true
religion jeans as if us [ __ ] we're
true religions use like that
we know that shit's overpriced you might
we might wear Levi's mm-hmm we might
wear academics mm-hmm we might wear that
no brand [ __ ] that no brand is perfect
that's not my brand we might wear them
things with the elastic bands in them
because you know we we got big tires big
big big tires big tires big your ties to
be my ties to be its ties to bigs my
ties your thighs a spice spice guys 180
he's Iowa's couch bow like what kept you
started for you do what you want so that
uh can you clean me up please
he's like yeah bro I got y'all finna
invert a poor twos on the side for the
cleanup time I was like no I don't know
what that means are my black friends
talk about it but um he's just wanna
play the fact that he has black friends
just because the comment was really
exactly my friends our y'all one whole
hour you cuts my hair white people do
not do that [ __ ] it's only like 15
minutes and he's sitting there in the
muhfuckas a briefcase a briefcase with
clippers I didn't know there was other
clippers I thought there was one so he
get going and he's talking to me about
life we're talking about girls you talk
about ball we talk about he made me feel
at home and then you know he is and I've
heard I've never heard these clipper
noises there's different noises he's
taking his time and stuff bro so then
here's our dude you good let me show you
say takes he's showing me like
everything you know with like I'm here
I've never seen the back of my head
before in this crystal speaking lines
are dude Chris so then I'm bout to get a
hold on bro he takes this warm towel bow
and puts that [ __ ] on my neck
the black barbers are sent from heaven
you guys are miracles thank you white
people need this thank you about every
black barber out there I don't know if
you are good oh yeah I'm so thankful for
you guys
I'm so sorry that my white people are
just mean to you you guys I'm letting
please do all the talking because I
don't cut my hair no you don't know what
the [ __ ] why I don't even get maintained
I literally wake up do this that said no
products you don't even do that so you
know if you wonder like hey boy what do
you know about hair make something like
[ __ ] [ __ ] stop stop you talking about
the boogie man as far as I'm concerned I
don't know [ __ ] about that world don't
talk to me about hair maintenance if you
want to talk about hair maintenance you
can talk to me about it
yo I don't buy anything about that
mmm-hmm part arms curls curls press
these girls you just want to run praise
like the Loch Ness monster Ness [ __ ]
dead business what the what the [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah we're not even talking about Creole
and you're acting all crazy
oh no because for more so there you have
it folks
black barbers I don't know what the
point this video was but it was amazing
wasn't it subscribe share like you
already know see alright that's it for
today's video hope you guys liked that
if you guys want to follow us we got a
Facebook we got Instagram we even got a
patreon page so if you guys want to give
us a little bit of something and that
would give you know yeah I'm saying no
okay and then we also have some t-shirts
we just started merchandising so if you
want a fuzzy shirts
those are available check out the links
below cuz we're gonna have a whole kinds
of merchandise that we're gonna be sound
to you guys because we know you guys
want to be about that Apple and peach
you already know what it is is there
anything else oh and we got our show
June 4th right that's when we cool art
gang be there June 29th cook up here in
Montreal les